We all have intrusive thoughts from time
to time and many of us,
for example,
will check whether we have our airplane
ticket before going to the airport.
More than once.
That isn't ocd tebow CD.
You have to have obsessions and
compulsions that impair your life and
are highly distressing and of rule.
A sort of rule book would be maybe at
least an hour a day.
But most of the patients that I work
with will obsess and compulsive for
hours a day and really their life can be
ruined.
So I have some patients will come to me
and say,
look,
I know I don't need to be washing my
hands like this,
but I can't stop.
And I have other patients who are really
not sure,
really not sure.
I mean they really believed that if they
don't wash,
maybe they'll actually get ill.
So there's that sort of range of
insight.
It's also true that someone in my office
can say,
you know,
I know the subway safe and I could touch
that pole.
But if I walk onto the subway with them
doing an exposure and ask them to touch
the pole in front of me,
they lose their ability to ha to,
you know,
remember that this isn't going to kill
them.
So obsessive compulsive disorder is a
disorder where patients have obsessions
and compulsions and obsessions are
intrusive thoughts,
images or urges that they find very
distressing and are very repetitive and
compulsion's our behavioral acts or
mental acts,
things they do in their head over and
over again to try to reduce the
distress,
that obsessions cause or to follow
specific rules.
So while all patients with ocd have
obsessions and compulsions,
um,
the content of the obsessions and
compulsions can really vary.
So one type of patient can have
intrusive concerns about contamination
and they baby washing,
doing elaborate washing rituals.
A different patient might have intrusive
thoughts about harming either other
people or harm befalling themselves.
And they,
for example,
might have rituals of checking to make
sure that the harm didn't happen yet.
Another type of OCD patient might have
what's called just so ocd where
everything has to be either arranged,
are ordered in a certain way or they
have to actually do things in a certain
way and they may be repeating and
rearranging and organizing all day long.
And finally,
there's a group of people who have what
we call intrusive taboo thoughts that
can be about sex or religion or,
or violence.
And often these are images that they
have.
And again,
they might have elaborate rituals to
reassure themselves that they actually
didn't actually commit any of these
acts.
Now,
it's not like ocd patients only have
one.
You know,
often ocd patients have more than one of
these types of obsessions and
compulsions together.
But that's sort of a flavor.
So there's a sort of simple version,
right?
Fear of contamination with washing
rituals.
But OCD can get really,
um,
you know,
sort of far out.
So,
for example,
I once worked with someone who,
um,
California was contaminated.
And so what it meant was,
um,
she couldn't have anything in her
apartment that had the name California
in it when mail a envelope had once
arrived to her mailbox that had
California on it,
her mailbox then became contaminated,
or for example,
um,
intrusive harm befalling.
You know,
I've had patients who,
uh,
worry that maybe they've driven over
someone as they drive and so they can't
make it to work because they're going
around and around the intersection to
make sure that they haven't,
uh,
run someone over.
But the harm can also be very,
very abstract,
not as concrete as that,
but very,
very abstract.
So,
you know,
there are many,
many,
many versions of OCD.
What we know is that when you do brain
imaging studies of people with OCD and
you compare their brain to the brain of
people who don't have a CD,
that there is a hyperactive circuit in
the brain that's been linked to a CD and
that,
uh,
hyper hyperactivity in that circuit has
been confirmed through animal studies.
And we don't think it's only that
circuit.
We think there are other circuits that
are likely involved as well.
But there's a real clear neuroscience of
this.
Um,
behavior of obsessions and compulsions
had the brain get that way.
And here we know less about that.
What we do know is that in some
families,
but not in all families,
ocd seems to run in those families.
And certain genetic studies suggest that
there is a familial contribution to a
CD.
But again,
not in all cases,
but exactly how that particular brain
circuit went awry in that particular
patient.
We don't know that we're working on it.
We don't know yet.
Yeah.